welcome to this video yeah this is a bit
different I'm playing on another YouTube
channel owner here Cotton's this is
international master correct
healing correction harder from the from
the US and we are playing a 10 minute
game with the 5 second increments so
this is a rapid time control it's a bit
of a middle-of-the-road
time control but the thing is we wanted
to get in such a game this kind of dual
commentary we both um do a video on it
and we had some problems arranging a
time and now we had exactly this time
frame and we said okay let's let's do
this this somewhat uncommon time control
but make sure that we actually get get
it done okay we have a mirach C point
position and he played the the Google
needs a variation this is with night XT
for Scott a good minutes irradiation and
let's see what happens
yeah this is a very very common line I'm
just thinking briefly a rook c1 some
didn't move all the sensitive here but
I'm a write a six and now Knight a form
yeah ninety five is also possible this
is the the lesser Jack the enterprising
option 95 this is in fact very very
Jewish okay so here there is 93 just
getting back there's also a G for this
idea I'm not 100% sure about the right
move on here
the 93 first or g-form think it's
night-night see three first but not not
100% positive about this oh really
hmm I didn't really knew that this was
possible maybe it is if I take with the
pawn bishops III really he will probably
just recapture right with this counter
play on a - yeah I have I have 95 of
course so it is not a problem here
95 is always possible with with an okay
position but still hmm I wonder we are
taking it does not seem right to me
really come on 95 was the best know
anyway the question is however if he
takes it and he probably must take it
yeah how to recapture see takes is very
very safe move but eb-5 might be
interesting and 85 he can't play before
him okay let's take him you know it
looks like he does not have any any
particular problem here maybe I am
screwed up some move order I don't know
interesting yeah well it's not like I
have any problems but it's also that I
don't have any advantage Roxy to Bishop
III he always gets the bishop out which
is somewhat somewhat annoying maybe I
take it take it and be careful
yeah I should probably attack this poor
information
yeah it's unfortunately not a very
exciting game but what what can you do
it's um it's very equal ish I guess yeah
I really don't know it's this b5
possible really it seems it seems to be
but maybe I'm also painting it on a bit
too dark here and it's not not so easy
yeah to explain the ratings the ratings
here look very weird this is this 10
minute and 5 second increment is
actually from from the ICC still a blitz
blitz game not a rapid game or standard
game so it takes the Blitz ratings and
my blitz rating is not very good I don't
play this challenge system at all
actually just sometimes it happens that
some interesting player challenges me
that I liked that I actually like to
play him check and then III take this
challenge and accept the challenge okay
King D 3 would be nice 95 at a lot so I
better better in 20 I guess
um yeah so my rating is very low he's
got a pretty decent one
but the playing strength like ours we
should be in the 2900 mark maybe above
that if you're really a good blitz
player this this some challenge blitz
time control is mostly three-minute
without any increment so this is also a
bit different to the to the typical
5-minute game ok White has this pressure
against b5 Adam really threatening to
take this pawn if he takes it
Bishop a6 I don't think is any good he
can play em play rook e8 we should be 5
and then push the apron probably to
promote it he does not need to react him
to this attack on the night I think
black can just take it and play a 5
maybe Bishop b5 but he's got night c4
yeah this is very equal ish somewhat of
them can can easily be traded down to
two nothing
hmm can like do anything active him
looks like 95 is interesting the set the
set thing about the movies I can always
just take everything off and and
continue from them yeah well okay we
should briefly look at Bishop a six but
I think okay ages a very clear solution
to this Bishop b5 a3 and the pawn will
probably just promote itself I have to
recapture me it's maybe an idea now to
calculate rook b8 and tending would be
one but I think I can still take a six
rupee one Bishop c1 Bishop b2 whoopsie -
should be good
King C - I mean yeah the interesting
question is what about a five here
probably play Bishop b5 I also want the
King to e2 and I get my rookie to play
this is not not very comfortable that I
don't have to look into play so Bishop
Bishop b5 I guess on does it make any
sense to play Bishop a6 first
so yeah everything's protected here I
guess King e2m just or is there a better
a task where no King e2 is fine the
bishop is always protecting a4 and he
cannot increase the pressure there it's
difficult to to make any headway him
yeah what can I do actually I can expand
on the King side a g4 h4 and basically
just stay put on the Queen side he has
no easy way to enter my position but
some yeah maybe he can try what he would
like to do is X square exchange the dark
squared bishop x' this would be really
helpful for white to at the end maybe
have this good night on c5 against them
against Bishop here on on b5 what can I
do
I can maybe try let's say Bishop c6
rupee one but I have have no real
invasion I can I cannot really invade on
them under a foul maybe if I go Bishop
c6 at some point I can think of taking
on c5 and then enter with the King King
III c4 this is in fact an advantage of
my position my King is my king is
playing that's that's helpful or my king
is some let's say quicker in enjoining
and joining the action
yeah is he threatening this this type of
create night p3 maybe yeah Luke see one
would be the the very obvious move here
but it stopped doing much really Roxy
one
mmm any way to play this a bit more
actively I wonder if there's some idea
with the pawn okay
yes I start to start with this move and
what I mean with some idea with the a
pawn is at the right moment to just take
on before and then let the upon run but
it's very difficult to imagine how this
should should work maybe I can try
Bishop to c6 and then ship c6 - z6 and
then yeah this is helpful anyway the
specials I don't really think what about
what is f6 son okay putting it on dark
squares makes some sense but my idea is
now simply to take on c5 maybe at the
right moment Bishop takes rook b7 is
certainly slightly more comfortable for
me and this ship takes DC I will go to C
form with the King and this is also more
comfortable for white of course the
opposite colored bishops are Jewish but
what can you do I wonder what about rook
before takes Bishop c5 d takes a5 am i
promoting I guess not but I came still
interesting
yeah I wonder if I should do that now we
should see five but certainly leads to a
position where I can hardly lose the
game anymore and I can still maybe press
a bit just a bit can I do something else
not really sure if I have something
something else and let's do that let's
do this it's very one-sided after that
Bishop takes does there might be even
Bishop d7 to e6 directly and then going
to to the seventh but probably rook d7
first is also fine I expect him to take
with the pawn actually but not clear if
he takes with the porn I would I have
have this five verses for him which is
not terribly mobile but somewhat mobile
if it takes with the point I need to
play King d3 first anyway to get to see
form
yeah what very slight admittedly pull is
based on more space better King on c4
and blacks King is not so easily
activated
he said cannot go to e8 and if he goes
ecigs well this is also in a way helping
me I'll just play King c4 or maybe - I
know Bishop d7 in this concrete kc6
Bishop b7 s winning straight away okay
so it's giving me a protected passer not
not bad okay let's see him how to how to
get get ahead in this position and b h4
g4 and possibly g5 I'm not sure that
this really helps
hmm or should I go with g3f form not
sure not sure
g4 g5 am sorry just play play rook f8
and and it's not clear that I have
gained gain much from it
are very very tough to to get them to
get any any progress going maybe I need
to get the bishop back actually and this
Bishop is so it looks nice but it's not
doing very much very difficult now maybe
if I was a good defense I mean at first
I thought this might help me but it it
does not really seem to be the case
he wants g5 maybe maybe can prevent it
for the moment
so I g5 I can just take
I was more thinking of f5 but I play
King D 3 this was my idea at least yeah
I guess this is very harsh here maybe
this was so too simplistic taking on c5
it's the kind of you can never lose the
game and try move but trying is very
little here black can also probably just
sit and wait and basically do nothing I
really can do much
the c5 really a serve was good it
prevents me from getting a pawn role I
was G 3 & 4 I can still try to to open
up the other Kings side with g3 enter
and f4 but not totally totally sold on
this I get the King here so that it
actually protects you form this was the
idea of putting the bishop back and the
King back so that the king is helping
with the King side play it's it's just
the problem once I have played a form I
really don't know what what the next
step could be
after f4 he just stays and just doing
nothing maybe maybe I can go f4 week f1
yeah the taking is really never an
option and f5m not sure that this is
doing much yeah probably
probably not much happening him but he's
taking quite some time maybe he saw
something some inconvenience that that
irritated him yeah I still think I can
go a form without any any big big
problem okay
what about age five now this is a moment
where I can actually play age five as he
is not on the GFR
it does not want to take this would be
very very unfavorable for the structure
probably would never create I can take
g6 I think this this is not quite nice
ya know I can actually take here
playbook h6 I start route g6 a group g6
doing I can also take here and operate
with the idea Bishop b5 rook d7
checkmate but you can take take F form
so that's not not the best taking and
chat group she say Eric g6 seems to
seems to save maybe I have to play rook
h3 taking Ferno not taking first marito
need to play this first and maybe get
the key no one also Bishop b5 as a nice
move
oh I didn't see if I wanted ah this I
did not seem that's unfortunate
mm-hmm yeah okay I guess I know winning
chances here as rubgy 3sm is threatened
this is really a bit of a problem
Oh can I can I do something here
I take take here where they can take it
look take skinny too and then we should
be fine probably not not risking much
here
okay let's do that
yeah still simply an oversight we should
be one I I simply didn't see Bishop III
I have f5 this is still still tricky for
luck with Bishop e5 rook d7 made as the
idea and rook g3 I can go King e2
attacking the bishop and still having
Bishop b5 as an idea so I think it
should be okay
but you know maybe Rukia should be fired
well tricky look g3 kini - maybe I'm so
better him
Bishop takes that's just a five
okay so if I go Bishop b5 it's almost a
major but not quite f5
maybe f5 I also have rook f7 now all the
time group age six it's not too
convincing and we should be five you can
take f4 is there is there some trick to
promote it probably not yeah yeah I
guess f5 is the best best winning chance
just hope I don't blunder blunder
anything anything else besides this
Bishop give one earlier check okay so
here
I'm a bit better here I guess Jeff
shouldn't be five
yeah he's getting C foreign and he can
go all the way to define that's not good
but really really great yeah yeah but so
came we have already passed the point of
worrying about that so we have seven
ends and grabbing the F pawn it's got
the C pawn this is this is a very
serious counter play
now maybe he can give the chicks'll okay
yeah I need to grab here anyway now yeah
hmm the question I also have d6 ya know
56 6-2 time morning maybe d6 am getting
this getting this quickly to d7 that's
that's probably best him in other cases
I'm not sure how quickly the pawn will
move and now loop c6 is a big threat
wait wait wait wait look f8 is promoting
the pawn or not he can go to before
woopsie aid just just just a moment here
check see - I can take
and yeah let's let's let's promote so
now can I somehow stop the porn
completely I don't think so but that KDF
pond should should still still win the
thing Bishop c4 to d5 and kingi a gem
and then it just promotes yeah at least
I found one win maybe it wasn't the
absolute best way to play but we should
be 5s in fact it's still a bit tricky I
can't go to G 7 I can go to g7 beauty
and then promote I wasn't she wasn't the
most precise way but it's enough
yeah this game is also an argument for
for increment it just is chest to the
very end and black resign not some
somewhat influenced by um by by the but
someone using on time usually discussing
the game yeah yeah he said where did I
go wrong and not totally sure it was
always a little something about hard to
hard to tell hard to tell I mean he's
just moving this at the moment and tough
to say it's um it's always always a
little something computer points out
will be one in this position being
technically alone a nerd
yeah SS thought it was equal yeah after
after Bishop takes e5 I think
yeah I hope you wanna also didn't miss
but I also didn't miss but here this is
the structure after I take on c5 I mean
it's it's really the kind of position
that white can can never lose yeah this
is also equal the line that he's showing
him yeah black had more multiple
multiple ways to probably trade this off
the way it it was played I think it was
slightly uncomfortable Bishop takes e5 I
mean it's not like maybe I should time
this better actually I can always take
it but he got this if Ivan yeah yeah
there there are ways to try to improve I
mean here I think it still should be
very dry but somehow after I got in this
f5 f5 is pointed out here by the
computer okay didn't didn't see that
there should be ways to equalize this of
course it's it's not like white was
winning all the way
but after h5 adhere it gets it gets very
tricky here here black black is in
slight trouble I overlooked Bishop you
want totally but um
yeah and and here yeah very rock g2 is a
misstep according to the Comfort it's
difficult to play yeah complete defense
certainly yeah very very difficult
technical endgame here it was good that
I always had some slight time plus so it
wasn't like I needed to move from very
instantly yeah this is peace putting out
the moves now this is a very technically
complicated endgame and here I guess I'm
winning yeah after this yeah no no I'm
really winning with the plus nine or
whatever at least it's it's a winning a
winning line yeah here the computer has
is also plus six yeah this this is
really beyond saving I could have could
have probably played it as simpler but
still the f-pawn should always promote
I'm too too quick with the king yeah I
hope you enjoyed this and make sure to
watch both commentaries he also made a
video on that to see both sides and I'm
also curious to to watch this
yeah I hope you liked it and thanks for
watching